hey 42 here throughout history there
have only been two instances of a
nuclear bomb being used on a human
population both at the end of World War
two and Russia myrrh and Nagasaki
225,000 people died as a result of just
two explosions from the deadliest
weapons that man has ever created but
modern nuclear weapons make little boy
18 kilotons and the more powerful fat
man 23 peloton's seemed frightfully late
modern nuclear weaponry is anywhere from
eighty to three thousand times more
powerful than fat man so what would
happen in the minutes and hours after a
nuclear weapon launch what would you
hear and see how would the government
react I will be using the United Kingdom
as the missile target for this
hypothetical doomsday scenario because
there is more information publicly
available about the UK's plans nuclei
and miss our response than any other
country but the response of the British
government and what British citizens
would experience is going to be
remarkably similar to any of a developed
nation let's say North Korea launches a
single ICBM or intercontinental
ballistic missile directly towards
London as Kim jong-un now claims he has
the capability to do so nukes travel at
approximately four miles per second once
they reach full speed it will take
roughly 40 minutes give or take a few
minutes depending on the nuke and other
factors for it to reach London but it
wouldn't take 40 minutes for London to
find out that certain death is heading
their way there are a multitude of early
warning systems in place if you travel
by car from York to the coastal town of
Whitby which I highly recommend by the
way you will pass for the stunning yet
bleak North York Moors four miles on it
you all come across nothing would eerily
quiet mossy and Heather speckled
in every direction but at one point you
will spot an enormous alien like
structure on the horizon this is RAF
filing Dale's a top-secret military base
that has the official motto vigilance
which means we are watching I have a
weird obsession with secret military
bases and this is one of my all-time
favorites it looks like it was plucked
directly out of the depths of the Cold
War or small spy movie nobody knows
everything that goes on at RAF filing
vales
but it is Britain's primary ballistic
missile early warning system built in
the 60s during the Cold War it forms
part of the US and UK's combined early
warning system along with other bases
this interlinked Network shares up to
the second intelligence between both
powers and forms an early warning system
covering millions of square miles
filing dale's solid state phased array
pyramid settled can detect missiles
satellites and pretty much any other
flying object within a five thousand six
hundred kilometer range in all
directions but if we were to rely on
filing dale's alone we would need to
wait for a North Korean missile to reach
Europe before it could be detected
leaving Britain with less than 15
minutes to prepare and respond but the
missile would pass through the territory
as several of a NATO allies who would
hopefully give us some warning because
of the trajectory of an ICBM the first
NATO allies such a missile would cross
is Norway on a tiny Norwegian Island
called vada there is actually a radar
station occupied by the u.s. that keeps
tabs on Russia but could also detect a
missile from Asia however there is one
more missile warning system that will
give the UK a much faster heads-up
satellites
hundreds of us operated satellites
orbiting Earth could detect the
extremely high heat signature of an ICBM
and as little as 30 seconds after its
launch from North Korea as soon as the
US knows about the missile it would very
likely and hopefully alert Downing
Street so the British government could
be alerted to the impending missile
strike in his little as one to two
minutes after its launch but even with
satellites bases such as filing veils
and vardø are still very useful as they
allow much more precise tracking of the
missile as it arced through its many
foul and mild trajectory and blazing
speed this much more granular tracking
data would be used for missile defense
systems which we'll discuss near the end
of the video
a likely best-case scenario is that
Britain has roughly a 20 to 25 minute
window to react to a North Korean
missile little is known about what
military response would be taken by the
UK and the u.s. to such an attack
because it's obviously top-secret but we
do have an idea of what information and
guidance would be delivered to the
general public and how during the Cold
War people infamously had a four minute
warning to an impending nuclear attack
modern technology allows for a little
longer than that
but not much realistically by the time
the public are warned of the attack by
the government there would be 10 to 15
minutes until the new kids during the
Cold War the UK government plan to use
the wartime Broadcasting Service to
broadcast a short message all radio
transmissions would be interrupted and
every TV would automatically switch on
and transmit the message to reach as
many homes as possible but the wartime
Broadcasting Service was shut down in
the 90s today it is easier but still
challenging to deliver a warning to
every citizen within minutes the
government has the ability to send a
text message to every mobile phone in
the UK at the very same time so this
would most likely be the first port of
call obviously upon receiving a text
message that a nuclear missile is
it's way the first thing that everyone
would want to do is contact someone else
so to prevent the telephone network from
being flooded and freezing up the
British government would first restrict
access to all base transceiver station
x' this would put every phone in the
country into receive-only mode your
mobile would be able to receive calls
and text messages
what's unable to send any this way the
government could reliably send further
instructions every few minutes what
would those instructions be well they
haven't actually changed much since the
days of the four-minute warning the
government would likely instruct
everyone to get to the most central
location within their house usually on
the stairs this way there will be the
most amount of dense material between
you and the deadly radioactive fallout
outside a 150 kiloton nuclear bomb like
the kind nuts north korea are suspected
to possess has the potential to
innocently spread deadly radiation in a
five kilometer radius which could prove
fatal to over a million people inner
cities such as London that death toll
would be severely reduced if everyone
took cover between a few brick walls
matter absorbs radiation a house is not
going to stop you receiving a
potentially deadly dose of radiation but
the more matter between you and the
radiation the better and the more likely
you are to survive because your body
will absorb much less of it however
those within a 0.6 kilometre radius of
the blast sites will be instantly
vaporized by the huge fireball resulting
from the bomb as well everything else
every single thing inside this area it
doesn't matter how thick those people
walls are and those within 1.2
kilometers of the blast don't stand much
chance either the bomb will create an
immense air blast that will instantly
kill almost 100 percent of people and
level every single building within
that's radius for those slightly further
away from the bomb who have taken
shelter in the center of their houses
they will need to wait at least two days
in the same spot that's roughly the time
it takes for outside radiation levels to
die down to a level that wouldn't cause
a gruesome death within a few hours from
just minutes of exposure radioactive
fallout would be carried by the wind
hundreds of miles from the blast site so
people all over the country would be
advised to stay inside and make do for
as long as possible before going outside
after two weeks the atmospheric
radiation levels would have dropped to
one percent of their initial level it
would be advised to not step foot
outside for at least not long the
government will likely advise everyone
to wash their hair as soon as possible
after the blast using shampoo to remove
radiation that has clung on to it though
there will also be a warning not to use
conditioner because conditioner actually
causes radiation to binds to hair the
advice would also suggest removing
contaminated clothing and placing it
somewhere away from you and your family
doing this can remove as much as 90% of
the radiation on your person it would
also be wise to wash often if possible
whilst all this is going on what would
the government be doing hiding in a
top-secret bunker of course although it
isn't all that secret before the missile
hits all those responsible for
coordinating the country's response the
Prime Minister Seanie and military
personnel and cabinet ministers would
move into the UK's crisis-management
bunker it's underneath Whitehall and
it's codenamed Pinder after an ancient
Greek poet of the same name whose house
stayed standing whilst the rest of his
city was reduced to rubble
Pindar is a huge underground complex
like in house and sustain hundreds of
people it reportedly has a network of
tunnels that go underneath and have
access to Whitehall Downing Street the
BT tower and Buckingham Palace there are
discreet unmarked doors all over London
that provide access to Pindar from
inside Pindar the Prime Minister would
be able to con her
to the Trident nuclear submarine control
center through offer is a retaliatory
strike but how will the officials inside
Pindar know when and if it's safe to
come out by listening to the radio of
course yes even in 2020 that is the
official protocol for the government to
follow if sequestered inside a nuclear
bunker specifically the government will
tune into BBC Radio 4's Today program
every day for three days since in the
event of a nuclear attack radio force
today program would be broadcast from
the top secret would Norton underground
bunker it is safe to assume that if it
sucks broadcasting after three days then
Britain has fallen it's estimated that
if a nuclear warhead hit London it would
kill over half a million people and
injure another million but would it have
to come to this
if a single nuke was fired at Britain
would it face certain annihilation it's
difficult to say but there are systems
in place that could come to our rescue
together the US and NATO have a
comprehensive network of missile defense
systems placed in key locations around
the world they're effective areas
overlap to provide full coverage across
Asia Europe and North America most are
manufactured by defense contractors
Raytheon there are a few different
systems currently in use what they all
like pretty much in the same manner
first satellites detect the missile
within a few minutes of its launch and
send its location to a command center
somewhere in Europe or America the
command center then instructs the
closest radar to the missile to track
its precise trajectory and speed this
information which rapidly relayed to one
of the many military bases where the
missile defense systems are installed
and permanently on stun by one or more
ballistic missiles will be fired
directly towards
enemy nuke with incredible precision it
takes a lot of Technology and
mathematics to hit an object the size of
a small car traveling through the upper
atmosphere at four miles per second at
the very last moment
the ballistic missile detaches and
launched with an explosive payload into
the nuke hopefully detonating it as an
altitude that is going to cause minimal
to human lives
the issue with missile defense systems
is that they are far from foolproof no
anti-missile defense system in existence
is guaranteed to neutralise every
hostile missile and because of the
immense power of a single nuke all it
takes is one to slip through the net and
millions could die also foreign powers
such as Russia and China have supposedly
developed anty anty nuclear missile
defense systems Toofer a cloak of Soviet
concealment and confusion over NATO's
precise eyes such systems known as
penetration aides usually involve
launching several decoy missiles
alongside the real one or the use of a
single missile containing multiple
explosive payloads called an Mir V so
that the anti-missile defense systems
don't know which one's a hit and are
overwhelmed or run out of ballistic
missile reserves although it may be
interesting to postulate about this
scenario we should all hope that it
never comes to fruition because if nukes
are ever used again against people they
will probably be humanity's darkest and
potentially final days thanks for
watching
I've recently lost my first book which
I'm crowdfunding through unban
publishing
it's called sticker flak in it a
thousand years of bizarre history from
Britain and beyond if you would like to
get your hands on a first edition signed
copy then head on over to unbound the
links in the description and pledge
today thank you